welcome to the dean's show
subscribe if you haven't already it's
eddie and usually i'm doing interviewing
we got mark shipper here how are you
doing mark good sir how about yourself
good thank god you're with dna info
correct mark's going to be interviewing
me today and i thought we let you guys
in on the action
how's it going mark going very well
tired after a training session yeah
i'll let you go ahead and do your job
sure absolutely let's uh
start with a basic one up top uh when
and why did you start the dean show and
what is its purpose as a show
as you see it the dean's show we started
back in
2006 and the primary purpose was
when i started to live this way of life
islam i started to see that it was
bringing
contentment peace satisfaction in my
life
gave me discipline gave me a good set of
rules to live by
helped me to be a better human being all
around i started to see certain things
on the
media that were antithesis to what i was
learning i started seeing this beautiful
way of life that's will live by over
1.67 billion people in the world
being associated with terrorism and some
of the ugly things out there
so i thought okay i'm an american i love
my country
people need to get educated and i
thought the media was a great way
i was learning this way of life and i
loved sharing it and i thought the more
i can educate people to have a totally
different perspective we can break
somebody's walls
and we can foster and nurture goodness
instead of
a lot of this hate that's arising from
misinformation
and people just not knowing yeah so that
brings up
another question you've been very
successful using social media
uh youtube other types of video media
uh some print media i think uh on the on
the
internet so what are some of your
numbers like what are your twitter
numbers youtube numbers
uh what kind of followers what kind of
viewings do you get for a show i mean
thank god we started off
just putting our content on
what was available at that time i think
youtube was
was uh kind of new we started putting it
out there then we got
involved with the local cable station
here in chicago can tv and then from
there
i kind of got on board late with some of
the facebook
twitter started utilizing this and
we also have people who have reached out
and wanted to broadcast
our shows on many of the satellite
channels
so we're on several satellite channels
that have potential viewership in the in
the millions
so we have a good following amount of
following on
the satellite tv and also we have
a few million on our couple million on
our facebook and hundreds of thousands
on the other big numbers so a lot of
people are watching
listening um so what do you see in
popular culture news media
now uh you know recently the
misconstrues are misrepresents
islam what we're seeing a lot is
the the almost like advertisement
out there and fear-monger mongering
that is creating a rift between the
people
and today we see
such groups out there that are being
given a platform that don't represent
islam
that don't represent muslims give some
specific examples who are you talking
about
daesh have you heard of this this group
called daesh
i used to call him isil isis yep now
abdul karim jabar he had a wonderful
quote you know six time world nba
champion everybody knows about korean
jabar he's also a muslim and
and i love on my show you see i define
words because people think okay muslim
arabs somebody maybe an alien or
something you know a muslim is simply
one who has chosen consciously
to submit to the creator to have a
direct dial up connection with the one
who created creation god almighty this
is
this is something that jesus did moses
and all the messengers of god
so this is what a muslim is in abdul
karim jabar he also accepted islam and
he makes this quote saying that
when kkk christians
when they go and burn or have burned
crosses in black people's yards
christians don't have to come out
condemning them because most people are
intelligent
enough to know that they don't represent
mainstream christianity
the same way if you look at for instance
there are over 1.7
billion muslims all around the whole
world from everywhere italy
germany france all over and
you see that cia reports have estimated
between 21 000 to 35 000
people who have joined this group isil
now if we go with the high number
let's say 35 000 you'll see that compare
1.6 let's say 1.7 billion muslims what
does that equal
to the amount that's in this group zero
point
zero one nine percent right time
fraction
now let's take 1920s when kkk were at
their pinnacle prime they had five
million members five million members
out of a population of around 106
million in 1920s
today you still have functioning
branches you can go online and you can
pick which one
you want to join because they're all
over the place now kkk is like the
white isis all right this is the same
thing
and most people are intelligent to know
they don't represent christians the same
way this group
who by the way mark people don't know
that
they are killing actually muslims are
the ones
who hate this group the most not only
are they defaming islam
they are also killing more muslims and
you don't get to see
just recently you had in beirut you had
an istanbul turkey
you had innocent people muslims who are
killed
we don't have press coverage for that
you follow me but as soon as some
deranged lunatic does something and
you know has anything he ate with a
muslim you know he had
uh a dog that had musli i mean a pet
named muslim names
whatever decade anything linked with
islam there you go 24 press
media press coverage on on on
um even reporting unbiased i mean bias
reporting you see that
this is something that is really
disheartening you know to to peaceful
um people who are out there who just
want to live like everyone else
you know and and and live with their
neighbors and be understood in the
correct way
but then you have media twisting it and
we're obviously made to look like
suspect now
yeah yeah um so
this is right down that same line as a
muslim do you feel it's an obligation
for yourself and
other muslims to counter the narrative
is it the responsibility of outsiders to
educate themselves
or ideally would you like to see a
combination of both muslims out there
countering the narrative
and people also educating themselves who
might not be muslim to get to figure out
what the truth is despite what the
popular
you know narratives might be as muslims
those who have
who live this way of life we're told to
share this message
to help eradicate
any kind of false fears that anyone has
through educating people
and it's everyone's individual duty
to go ahead and try to dispel one of
these
many of these myths that are associated
with islam but at the same time
you know you will often hear you know
these cliches that
that are thrown out there that why don't
muslims condemn terrorism
you follow me yes so every time let's
say
someone will go and blow up
a abortion clinic or commit a mass
shooting or these kkk
neo-nazis who do horrendous acts
and their religion is not mentioned they
you don't have recently you had what was
called hiroshima on the light switch
many people didn't hear of
a gentleman by the name of crawford he
was developed a weapon of mass
destruction
and he was a christian members of their
church started coming here to pray for
them they were unaware of the details
that surrounded their arrest and unaware
that crawford was a self-proclaimed
member of the klu klux klan
he's also accused of carrying an
animosity toward muslims and
targeting them in this attack members of
the barkersville christian
church say they are shocked by this and
think it's all a mistake adding
the crawfords are nice giving people who
aren't the type that would be
involved in a terrorist group there
obviously is many more details
and you didn't we didn't expect his
whole church to come out they were
actually saying good things about him
saying we didn't expect this he's good
family
man what not but he was planning to kill
president obama
he was planning to to decimate and kill
muslims the murderous plan allegedly
called for attaching an industrial grade
x-ray machine
to a specially designed triggering
device stored in a truck
the weapon would be mobile shooting
concentrated doses of radiation
on unsuspected targets who would die
within two weeks
among the potential target sources say
muslims and president obama with this
this contraption that this stuff you
can't make up this was this stuff out of
a sci-fi movie that this
this x-ray type of of
uh mass weapon of mass destruction would
go through a wall penetrate
and 500 people two weeks later can just
end up dying
you didn't hear much about this at all
in the media people don't know about it
imagine if muslims were doing this this
this is something unheard of
so now uh we we should
as as human beings be making this human
connection
getting to know our neighbors and really
not
swallowing everything we're being fed by
many politicians
who are using fear for a certain agenda
to divide
and these are the things that at the end
if we
are intelligent enough to go to the
source go into you had many of these
rallies
recently in arizona and other places
people
having derogatory t-shirts saying really
hurtful things demeaning things
and then when they went into one
particular man jason ledger and his
uncle say they've been invited back to
the mosque for more discussions and they
plan to go
this time the t-shirt will stay at home
i feel
that me and a few people like my uncle
paul and the muslim people taking time
to talk to each other
i feel that we change the thoughts of
some people and they changed the
thoughts of me
paul specifically said i will never wear
that shirt again when i took a second to
sit down and listen to them
and actually enter their mosque and go
in and watch some of their prayers it
was a beautiful thing
and they answered some of my questions
that i had when he went into the mosque
he sat with muslims
he had a totally different perspective
yeah because he was educated because he
made the human connection
yeah yeah okay this is um
this is right down the same line maybe
it's it's going deeper into what we're
talking about right here so
uh you'll often hear people say
where are the muslims out there shouting
that you know we hate these murderers
and isil or daesh
the governments in syria et cetera are
are muslims doing this
and not being heard or is it a case of a
double standard where because
islam is not the native religion of the
quote native religion of the united
states
maybe it faces tougher scrutiny and
judgment than another group might
thank god that the dean show we're going
on since 2006
that's over 10 years 500 episodes
we have brought on many of the prominent
speakers scholars in america and around
the world
and we have condemned such actions you
know
in the quran this is very clear in
chapter 5 verse 32
it states god almighty is stating that
whoever kills one innocent
being is after you kill the killed all
of humanity
if saving one innocent being as if you
save the world so the texts are clear
that hurting innocent people
non-combatants this is something that is
definitely not a part of the teachings
of islam
now we've also had scholars
big organizations such as care and other
groups come out and condemn these things
but it's sad to say that we don't have
the
platform nor many of these organizations
such as
the dean's show and others are not being
given the microphone
to go ahead and let the masses hear our
voices
another thing is real beautiful when you
hear i just heard a
president bill clinton you know him
everybody knows bill right
bill clinton was giving an account
of what he portrayed as the majority of
muslims how they are in the u.s
because it was a new york daily article
that
was talking about a yemeni muslim
who had been working at a convenience
store
and he got stuck up bill clinton is
narrating the story
looked at it and said i've just had this
job for a year this is not my money and
it's not yours
and he slapped at the gun hand the
person standing closest to him
that guy is more representative of most
muslims in america
it's interesting we have this on our
facebook page you can see it
and he said that a man came in at
gunpoint to stick him up said give him
give me the money the muslim opened up
the drawer took the money he was about
to give him he said
you know what i've just only had this
job for a year
this is not your money it's not my money
i'm not giving you the money and he
smacked the gun
out of his hand the gun actually uh
went off bullet hit the counter the man
realized look i'm in the middle of you
know this new york city i better get out
he got away he left off the muslim got
the rest of the day off his employer was
very happy went home prayed
and thank god and then at the end bill
clinton said you know what
that guy is more representative of most
muslims in america
this is the majority of muslims here in
america these are the people that
basically saying that americans need to
know about he gave another example of
kenya so the muslims went around giving
headscarves to the christian women and
otherwise trying to
disguise them and they risk their lives
to save the christian minority where
there was a
group of muslims and christians riding
on a bus
and a terrorist group came
and was trying to separate the muslims
and the christians
and what happened the muslims ended up
disguising
the women putting hijabs on them and
risked their own lives to save the
christians
to risk their lives to save the
christian minority
so these stories people don't hear about
these stories the majority we talked
about iso dash
0.019 over here and
24 7 coverage all day and night that's
all you hear
but now all the good that muslims are
doing you don't hear about these stories
it's nice to hear president clinton
yeah you know share share this a couple
good stories from him
um all right so bringing it back uh
locally a little bit
uh how is life in your opinion from what
you've seen and what you hear in chicago
for a muslim because sometimes you'll
hear these
claims that life in america as a muslim
after 9 11 has been
a form of hell but that doesn't seem
quite accurate
so has there been any specific threats
against your community been targeted for
anything
or do you find that it's a more
complicated situation sometimes it's
very good
other times you might run into pockets
of people who are more prejudiced what
is
life like been in chicago in your
opinion is it a big deal or no
i think chicago like new york and some
of these more urban cities the big
cities where you have
a mixture of nationalities religions
it's not as bad as if you go outside
some of these
areas where people haven't really gotten
out the box right you're right
where you have many people who
if you don't look like them talk like
them
sway like them have an accent like them
or slang like them
it's not you're not one of them and
anything else you're just
you're not in and
when you don't have access
to the information and someone
also is not with you to make that human
connection you don't have a taxi driver
that's a muslim possibly like you do in
chicago
maybe you don't have like here most of
the the doctors are muslim doctors right
engineers scientists so you're able to
professors you're able to go to the
university and your professors
professors are muslim
and you got you get to make the human
connection you go to the doctor
it's a muslim doctor human connection
right right and there's that good in
every human being
you follow me that needs to be nurtured
and when it's nurtured
through the right channels then
like nelson mandela had said beautiful
statement he said that
nobody is born hating
that people are taught this so now
you're in a rural area you never met a
muslim and now you hear
some of these politicians spewing this
hate pumping you up
making it seem like the boogeyman is
coming to get you you follow me
that fosters it you're taught that right
so we need to teach them how to love and
that's what the d
show is about and muslims are
the majority about trying to get the
message out really
trying to be represented the right way
to show that we are
a community of peace we have a greeting
of peace peace be with you
we pray for peace we want peace we live
a way of peace
yeah well said uh all right closing in
here just a couple more questions for
you
um so we spoke a little bit the other
day and you gave me
some specific examples of outreach
you've done in the community
uh what were some of those with your
professor friends
your doctor friends you go out and i
think there was some outreach to gang
members
some other just community open houses
what were a few of those things that you
do
yeah the muslim community is very active
in
feeding the poor and setting up
different we have a
a free clinic it's on the south side is
called iman
and they're doing some great work these
are doctors who come together
people who don't have insurance they're
not able to afford health care
they have free health care they have
pantry set up feeding the poor
and this is what it's about making the
connection helping the community
we also we do open houses recently me
and my
good friend dr sabil we were at a
mosque in bloomington
we invited the mayor came in for a short
time you had the police chief the
commander
a priest and community members
and they got to hear what islam was
about
they got to ask questions the human
connection was made
at the end nothing but good feedback
everyone had a great time ate some food
we got to
interact and everyone was like more
people need to learn this
more people need to be educated because
it's through that education
through the human connection that's
where a lot of this
hate false fear and these misconceptions
that are out there can dissimate can be
eradicated and we can
start to understand each other's
neighbors because we have to understand
that
you know muslims ain't going nowhere
right christians ain't going nowhere
right we're here we're living together
so we need to get to know each other
get to know our neighbors and need to
work together to live together
in peace yeah so these are these are
friends and neighbors scenarios this is
going out and realizing these people
uh muslims are not in any way others
they're americans they live next door
deal
and they're just people exactly like you
are so that's what these things are
all right um so last question here we're
at your jiu jitsu academy so let's let's
get one there um
how do you think this academy fits into
all of this in terms of the example
it sets for how you live your life is it
a great advertisement
uh for how you live your life maybe for
islam maybe for the rest of your family
or do you like to keep it neutral here
and just leave by an example how does
this all fit into your plan
as soon as you come in to the academy
there's a statement on the wall that
says the best of you are those who have
the best manners
and character so along with when you go
back and you look at some of the ancient
samurai traditions
there was principles that were involved
in
martial arts a lot of we've lost a lot
of that
it was a controlling of one's ego
oneself and to now a lot of days what
happens people
learn and train martial arts the ego
becomes bigger and they become
destructive in the community right right
doing some you see many of the
ufc fighters mma fighters this guy's
beat up this girl this guy's in jail for
this this guy's in cocaine this guy's on
this drug
you see what you have when you learn and
you have a good teacher
not just teaching you how to throw a
punch how to knock someone out how to
submit somebody
but at the same time helping to work on
the heart
on the spirit these things nurturing
that good
inside that they can have a reference
point to look back to
and to control that ego
by getting this confidence that the
martial arts teaches you at the end when
you have a complete
to your martial art not just i'm a tough
guy and i can knock someone out
but at the same time my manners are
better my character is better my
self-confidence is better i'm a better
human being
all in every aspect i now
am confident that if someone tries to
because it's self-defense defending
oneself
i'm not and we stress this that now if
anybody's caught
doing anything disruptive in the
community or or out there you know
using this in the wrong way they're not
part of this they'll be
um expelled from this team they we
stress that this is something that
at the end is supposed to empower you
but at the same time
you have a responsibility at the same
time now
you carry this with you but you have a
great responsibility so we try to cover
every aspect that now will help
to make a complete martial artist you
follow me
not just one or two but
every aspect as was done in karate kid
have you seen karate kid yeah he's the
best
yeah yeah great movie all right let's uh
let's close down with uh what does
the dean show the d means something
specifically doesn't that what does the
dean show me
absolutely uh the dean
is a word that means the way
d-e-e-e-e-e-e-e-e-e-e-e-e-e-e d-e-e-e-n
yes some people say oh what's up mr dean
no no
dean is a way of life and again
you know there in the essence of
education
look we try to make the information
known
who muslims are what muslims believe
it's not our job to try to
convert anybody you know a lot of times
when we bring up religion
most people they it's a personal subject
but here at the dean show it's something
that
now there's all this massive story about
islam we want to show islam as an open
book
this is what it teaches it's for
everybody if you like it
you can have it also if not at least you
understand it now
so deen is a way of life a way of life
we say that was lived
by all the messengers that the creator
sent to guide humanity out of his love
he sent jesus and many people don't know
this that you cannot be a muslim one who
is submitted to the will of the creator
not the creation unless you
love and revere jesus as one of the
mightiest messengers of god
again commonalities we have so imagine
you're hanging out with somebody
and now you're like you like baseball me
too you like jiu jitsu me too
you like italian me too you got all
these you got about a hundred things in
common
but you got a couple things that you
don't agree on you can politely
agree to disagree on these things right
because the small things
that are actually the things that that
we don't agree upon
is that jesus was god that he called
people to worship him but we love jesus
as a messenger of god
and this is something that that we we
make clear we believe in original
goodness not original sin so those are
the things that are
are the differences but now there's so
many commonalities that we love his
blessed mother there's a whole chapter
named after
the blessed mother the virgin mary in
the quran there was just recently a
professor hawkins
who is having her position i believe
terminated because she stood in
solidarity with muslims she's a
christian professor
and she wore what you see on
mary jesus's mother and what's called
the hijab it's just a modest dress
that she put on that's actually if you
look at it's part of
the teachings of christianity it's in
the bible so now we point out these
similarities in this way of life
right that we're not the antichrist that
we don't we love christ
that uh we worship the same god we have
a different way we believe in pure
monotheism that we don't worship
anything in creation
but only the creator of creation that's
it that's it done
and you have a right to your way we have
a right to our way but at the end let's
try to understand each other
and by understanding each other that's
how we can live in peace
well said hopefully we reached some
understanding today
it was enlightening i'm out of questions
so thanks for uh thanks for having me on
thanks for talking for dna info
thank you very much for having me
appreciate it god bless you thank you
and i thought i'll let you guys in
on this interview i'm usually
interviewing people
but mark had wanted to interview me so i
thought you my
viewers out there on the dean show get
the benefit i hope you enjoyed
and stay tuned for more exciting
episodes of the dean show subscribe if
you haven't already peace be with you